[Music]
what's up gamers and presidenta is here
boots freaking hype for a livestream I
don't even know if you can hear me okay
I do think this is epic
[Music]
great I just realized I forgot something
let's take a guys actually I can lay the
music play
[Music]
sorry sorry about that welcome everybody
to the best livestream you'll ever
witness thanks right everybody
why is his song so goddamn high welcome
to Tropico 6 made a live stream
everybody this game has no bridges we're
freakin good guys I just love how they
sent me this hat by the way that's how
you know you want to do a sponsorship
because you get a hat like this how are
y'all doing great too many comments to
read hello everybody
changing the mood up a little bit very
nice very sexy this is gonna be a good
time we're gonna play some tropical six
today if you guys want to check out the
game check out download link in
description use the referral link
everybody
LSE damn thing its SME the El Presidente
pudy pie
can you stop with the anime sound I
haven't even done it are you gonna dress
Logan in today's video but first of all
it's tropical town boys what's the flag
in the back
that's Bangladesh or you gonna do it you
don't know your Flags ridiculous what do
you mean animes Sam stop trolling me
okay it's waiting for people to get in
here
where's Bangladesh again it's in the
Nordic region's say the Nordic mythology
country I look like a Russian officer
that's not really what I'm going for
Russian Nordic region no one knows it
doesn't exist
a very nice be careful with bad words
it's okay
I always know what I'm doing I'm just
playing as a dictator I don't understand
how anything can get wrong out of this
what am I wearing this is my pajama this
is my outfit when I have a day off and
Sunday after all but I wanted to scream
for you guys make it a bit different
make it a bit interesting a very nice
[Music]
how often do i streamed never I'm not
even streaming right now
stalling supporter question mark all
right should we just jump in Jesus let's
just jump into it guys the capital of
India that's right all right
where are we hey it's Tropico time this
game is kind of difficult I need a I
need some of you guys help for this I
hope you guys know this game if you if
you don't know the game I urge you to
download it right now and then try and
help me because I played a couple I
think I can play like an hour and a half
of the tutorial and it feels like I've
learned maybe like a fifth of the game
but it should be fine click new game
you're welcome
where is that Asha messed up okay shut
up about the bridges goddamn it we
haven't even started yet okay so I can
customize I'll goddamn it I have the
I've been sitting on these cigars at a
home for the longest time I forgot to
bring them okay how does should I look
like I guess like I look like right now
[Music]
like a soul dear ethnic type Latino Wow
okay there are a couple others okay coke
Asian everybody this is what I'm talking
about what I talked about customization
alright this is it boys only two genders
I see okay
can I change
these are the glasses of a true dictator
hey look it's keemstar everyone or I
can't change my hat do I want all right
this is looking a bit - there we go
okay now it's starting to look like me
no legs to see this is what I'm talking
about this game this game knows what's
up
no I want the actual hat that I'm
wearing otherwise oh there we go
there it is beautiful I guess I guess
you can customize your house as well we
don't really have to do this but why not
a meteor why not a cherry tree that's
kind of cute all right yeah that's it
let's jump into it you're like bin Laden
Wow thank you so much this is gonna be a
great lecture I hope I make it out of
live I'm scared of playing this game all
right new game I guess should I do
missions or sandbox I never tried
sandbox but I feel like I'm not good
enough to try it
ask her it lets the sandbox volcano map
I I am familiar with starting money
unlimited maybe I'll start with 2 mm
okay
wait how do I hit start notice again see
ya hope you don't get controversy I
think it's too late for that I just have
to commit at this point I'm gonna be
screaming for 3 hours so we have a lot
of dictator time mines he has to deal
with this everywhere day hey what does
that mean huh look at this look at this
beautiful is my mansion looks similar to
my youtube house okay so I know I know
this game alright to be a good dictator
the number one thing you have to do what
is this banana plantation what I my poor
we're gonna have to build some real
money makers some minds that's right
Mining time what should we mine gold why
not I can't do that
what can I mind then Iren I can iron
iron okay we need to get so actually I
don't even need money I can mine gold
no coal this is ayran lame okay there we
go let's build those and then we got to
connect it with a road see I know how to
play games wait how do I connect it oh
it's already connecting perfect see I'm
the best leader of all time okay
[Music]
we're just getting started what's next
oh yeah we need to build it and then
hire people this is quick build it make
it easy I guess we have to get some
immigrants all right let's get some
what's my goal I guess it depends like
if we want to be a communist or
capitalist what do you guys think what's
your favorite dictator great question
that's just so many to pick from
[Music]
communists
Wow I see how it is hey build a bridge
shut up can I can I
sorry guys this game doesn't have
bridges in it I hate to disappoint you
all right well communists it is let's
see where is it I know you pick like
later okay oh yeah we only have banana
trade not enough licensed trade weights
I can only harvest banana almost-human
protocol all right that's good enough
communist the hell is wrong with you
I feel like maybe I don't know enough
about the game to play sandbox yet maybe
I should just switch to mission but I
don't know am i good player obviously
I'm the best player okay if I was a
communist what would I build a rum
distillery best right everybody right
freakin here
epic wall street journal' PewDiePie oh
yeah no it's happening this is it voice
build the wall can you build walls in
this game this is the real question what
am I even doing that's a great question
I guess we have to build taverns get
people interested I build that cut okay
great
it wouldn't surprise me if you could
actually see that that's right so far
doing so good okay what do you want what
is it
[Music]
fulfill a trade route with the crown
crown standing fulfill export trade ride
with the crown export trade I don't even
know how to do that we're playing
Tropico six everybody turn the sound of
game up okay I can do that
build an LGBTQ society yeah why not
that's the point of this game you can
build whatever you want I should buy in
tannery actually we'll get there
eventually although I'm already rich so
this is like begging for trouble
sounds pretty lit background you got
damn right
turn the game sound down all right well
you boys need to make up your mind build
a safe space that's right I care about
my citizens we could build a circus
coconut harvesting I think I should get
more banana because that's like the the
only thing I got going for me which one
is eyes coconut cuts down trees boats or
is it industry
wait which one is banana Cu plantation
okay
there we go
yeah let's do another one of those thing
did I pick banana I didn't [ __ ] cancel a
banana time Pig llama
okay crocodile in what the [ __ ] do I
know you never heard of a crocodile
plantation don't build a bridge think I
really appreciate all the tips guys this
is what I this is the kind of tips I
wanted when I play this game okay corned
beef wants corn she could have told me
that two seconds ago goddamnit alright
let's let's cancel this cancel all right
let's build corn then she wants corn I
got you right here
how much money do we have [ __ ] we're
running alone can you starve your people
I'm pretty sure you can which we will
not do I'm a very caring very generous
leader still the gamesound all right
I'll just keep it where it was then
build the stripclub while you can build
all kinds of entertainment I really
appreciate all the help in the
suggestion guys it's very epic keep it
up all right how long for this to finish
all right let's just build more corn
then which one is a plantation okay
okay this is epic look at this road boys
look at this road
it connects perfect look at this road
okay no one builds roads like I build
roads it's my number one thing god damn
it look at this I make I make my I make
it efficient okay I don't know what to
tell you guys more crocodile please
oh you're right I did actually destroy
it now I feel a bit bad alright so we
need to build like houses for them
because I guess my citizens need
somewhere to sleep I know right
pathetic or should we build a bunk house
that's right they sleep in bug dish
while I sleep is that the verb for bug I
mean the plural while I sleep in my
mansion that's right here here you go
I'm a very generous leader what can I
say
I'm sure it's really hard not to say
anything bad in this game everything is
just political this is H of Empires for
it yes even better
Tropico six baby check it out link in
description you know I have my mansion
here I should just tweet out tweet out
on Twitter how away we should let in
more people in this city while they
sleep there's just no space in my house
unfortunately no one can fit in here you
guys can sleep over here though it's
fine we got plenty right here alright so
let's see if I remember okay alright
let's stop banging guys let's stop
banning anyone hold it like my stuff
let's start banning anyone that talks
about bridges we should probably think
about expanding though the problem is
how do you expand without building any
we should expand over here
I think cuz here we can probably farm
stuff like mines can we mine we can mine
gold hair bows rose that's right that's
what you are
okay alright we're gonna be rich now the
problem is how do we transport the how
are you not producing corn yet you're
useless where's my corn ah you don't
have a road Jesus Christ cry more oh my
god are you kidding me
goddamnit just put the rope what about
you you're producing corn at least but
then hire some immigrants then I don't
care
goddamn it useless
demolish a goddamnit
you're signing mine well I could dictate
there by the minute alright we need more
money what what is it there are too many
unemployed citizens oh---but where where
we people working what are you talking
about empty stock why is it empty stock
why is it empty stock what are you doing
all right you're all fired
why is it empty in stock tanneries
because I don't have licenses all right
that could be it okay I gotta buy the
trade licenses of gold yeah and rum yeah
that's it that's it now work goddammit
work what are you doing where are you
going alright I'm done with you this is
what happens when you don't work for El
Presidente where's she going
where you going
do I not even have people that can kill
okay
she's done and she's gone cool see this
is what happens if you don't work you're
fired
by dying all right so is it working now
the more the better produces leather oh
my are you kidding me I don't have
license for that what do you think I'm
Rach where's the leather rum
I don't need letter we have banana logs
let's do tobacco come on why is no one
working okay well this one should be
working now empty and stock sugar
I actually genuinely needed help okay
oh oh oh okay there we go
no I did not kill a women just do
missions already shut up I know exactly
what I'm doing
you need trade routes and stuff for you
produce trade routes didn't I have that
yeah that's just what I got right trade
route is already active look it's all
redacted I buy some tracer oh I see
is that what I was missing the boat will
bring the goods what god damn it you
goddamn useless all right maybe I
shouldn't even build a teamster I can't
hurt
okay I'm testing my way forward here
build on water thank you for the tip you
guys are super helpful appreciate it
what about the gold mines god dammit I
forgot they need to wait I need to
figure out how to play okay wait okay
hey I saw an helpful comment you need
landings to for people to land and team
support yeah team sorry I just build the
team so that's right you'll need
landings okay for Lera landing there we
go okay okay okay
epic epic there you go what else do you
whine quick build I thought I said quick
build
they can walk from there it's not
connected god damn it oh god damn it
roads
my biggest oh wait that's fine actually
hey look at that that actually worked
out great
spill the proper landing okay it's good
thing I played the tutorial and forgot
literally everything there we go
you need a cattle ranch and your
factories don't have raw materials
producing work you need a cattle ranch
and sugar plantation oh they don't have
the materials because they need how do I
know what materials they need
okay well rum needs sugar right so I
need a sugar plantation oh I see I see
got it yeah yeah just give me the money
look look who's producing corn everybody
haters said it was Photoshop okay so now
I need a cattle ranch okay thanks guys
this is epic there we go
what is this PewDiePie actually playing
the game stop building penis I'm pretty
sure I haven't done that
build a memorial for sleeping I mean you
can build some inspiring stuff I know or
some military so I guess I don't have it
[Music]
okay so now once these are done yeah we
have workers no that's the mine alright
let's get some foreigners don't make any
jokes okay moving on open tslot yeah
yeah work work god damn it give me the
corn come on Papa needs corn for who
knows why
what am I missing what do you want all
right let's do that list of the mines
it's fine so I need to build a lot of
citizen towards to get them boats okay
let's do landing here and then a landing
over here there we go
actually you know what we could do I got
a crazy idea I got a crazy idea we could
build it does it not work shut up I'm
really good at this okay okay my mines
are useless what's in the way uneven
terrain oh god damn it so how do I even
the terrain just okay I know I can do it
I can do it I can do it here we go here
we go here we go here we go
how the [ __ ] do I build a bridge cannot
build bridges across the sea in the :
colonial era I'm in the wrong era guys
thank God for the colonial era it looks
like we can't build a bridge guys no I'm
not sweating shut up okay we're still
not producing in the [ __ ] rod and the
tannery is completely useless make sugar
what are you doing want goddammit she
says we're playing Tropico it's
literally in the title guys oh my god
what is it I like that I like that a lot
you have an average away an average
revolutionaries approval oh right we
have to check the what people think
about me I guess I don't know why where
is it oh okay so we're in the colonial
era okay so you all right how do i okay
shut up
all right so overall happiness 35 people
are happy that's pretty good
unemployed citizens three okay I'm sorry
but if you're not employed you're
useless for me
all right now you're not my problem
anymore now I swear to God
alright let's just build corn then god
dammit well Oh are these not done yet
Jesus Christ you're building too slowly
alright we need to speed up the corn
process more corn I don't want it near
my house I don't want anyone working
near my house there we go
that's a perfect place for that bail god
damnit
[Music]
I'm not building any bridges and I'm not
building any worlds okay shut up let's
start banning people all right
Fisherman's Wharf is a good way to get
food
okay I'll build that thing thanks for
the tip bro wait what you have to build
them here oh I see all right perfect an
actual helpful comments how about that
now I have not done an oopsie I never do
please what happened to all the coins
why okay fine fine fulfill export trade
route with the crown
all right what else do we need pineapple
well definitely we want gold all right I
forgot that we have this stupid mine's
God construction workers cannot reach
this conclusion I connect island with
landings or bridges alright just build
it just build it goddamn it okay now
we're gonna build the most epic epic
road ever made come on yes that's how
you build roads that's what I'm frickin
talking about now all right you got a
landing right oh yeah we got to build
like a bus station where are they
we don't have that yeah okay we're not
there yeah fine fine
you know what I don't need it great tips
in the comments really appreciate okay
we did it give me my money no to
immigrants just take the money it's a
video game it's a joke okay so moving on
fulfill export trade route with crown
yeah yeah all right no no no no no no no
no no we're doing that
we just need seven guys more approving
of us who's not approving who's not
approving huh
who doesn't like me I will kill you all
right we can see here what we're
struggling with we don't have any
electricity apparently I need to say
Liberty okay fun coverage you can have
our healthcare don't make me laugh
what's the point of health care
ridiculous all right cool all right
you're actually doing something that no
you're not god [ __ ] damn it all right
all right okay
Oh No
god damn it what are you uh what did she
say
all right we're building pirates it's
the only way for me to make money
clearly I don't even know if we can do
that we can build add onion that's
always something
let's go online and transport goods
production to process building transfer
I think we need one of these
have I not build one of those already oh
I have okay nevermind [ __ ] I whatever
trying really hard not to swear
listen I can swear it as much as I did
this I don't have any fire station ah
okay okay I have a plan just demolish it
send helicopter you idiots
how could this happen oh I can feel the
pyro come okay
it's pretty cool let's do that yeah yeah
this is epic look at that now we can
make some extra money yeah
pirates that's how it's done let's
actually rush this one and then we're
gonna we have a mime a mime amen
Lucas Romero everybody okay I don't care
all right Lucas Romero we're gonna send
him out on a pirate quest for heisting
Stone Edge yes that's what we're gonna
do
go forth my pirates and make me buy that
money oh you're not connected way way
anyway I'm not connected to the road
okay there you go
soda man oh you're still on fire well
what do you expect me to do about it
okay well you're gonna die anyway
so I can't even build the fireman
station
can't wait for the coots backhoe article
listen I haven't even done anything bad
yet we haven't even gotten started
well I'm really just trying to put this
chord okay which I'm doing a great job
oh it's bananas whatever okay all right
what do you want the crown yeah yeah the
crown don't produce bridges I'm not
gonna do it because you know why
where's the stupid Island are they even
connecting is anyone even using these
almost human protocol I mean that's
pretty good
all right we have Beatrice Smith all
right where are you follow her get to
work get to work Beatrice go to work get
a job bear trees you work at the mine
okay I don't get more people in this
city go to work be it where's she going
job is over there my god the
incompetence yeah sure okay wait build
residential I need oh my god I don't
care about the people way way way we
need food Wayne Wayne we what about me
huh more houses okay all right I'll
build more houses there you go that's a
tavern all right you know what not in my
city okay
you guys live in the suburb spill let's
build it over here you guys can live
over here not in my house
a mansion I had to pay to unlock it all
right fine here you can live in the
mansion a bunkhouse
okay I'm generous I'm feeling I'm
feeling generous and then another
country has okay all right
I'm already window maker I think I'm
doing pretty good actually I'm pretty
pretty proud of this epic bro army
nation as it's called what is this now
oh okay cuz it burned down or another
country ass I could just just rebuild it
when we can we build nukes we'll get
there eventually can I build nukes
actually inspiring billboard will build
that as well okay I guess I needed to do
more trading some fish oh yeah we should
do that because we have the fisherman
it's like I do one thing and then I
forget no road connection when we
ain't--we don't you cry babies you know
that El Presidente
the road is not connected I don't
understand how that's my problem
oh my god just connect the road please
how is this not connecting yeah
oh I see painting you did you built a
road for us you're too kind I know
you're not worthy there we go okay fine
all right now
are you missing anything else okay I
guess we need to hire some foreigners
I don't have internet yeah I don't have
any electricity all right so they're
doing stuff now newspaper Bild the
newspaper okay I guess we have to build
PU news everybody
or is that media newspaper
okay Pugh news the opinions is it worthy
sanctum it needs to be built next to my
mansion just to make sure it's unbiased
it will I hire Gloria Borger absolutely
all rights almost then Raphael Raphael
Gomez is the most trustworthy most
honest working media and also of course
of course
Josefa Gomez love her never met her
because that would be against my my bias
that would be conflicting bias but other
than that I think it's doing pretty
great all right so now how's my mind's
doing how's my stone-age trade going how
are we doing over here guys how is it
freaking going how do I check in the
progress how do I check the goddamn
progress of the rain don't care Sofia
please employee of the month who's that
I've never done any of this I don't
really know how to use it where is it I
know there's a red bar or something
god damn it where are you oh wait I know
how to do it you click here and then
open rage screen you're not even
you're not even doing anything send part
well then do it God a me treasure hunt
then go on a treasure hunt
go on a goddamn treasure hunt Papa needs
money alright if okay now they're
working good good
more money gave me that money we need to
destroy t-series the goal this mr. nuke
nevermind nuke nothing this is
impossible it's like I can't even joke
okay alright yeah what is it
citizens up higher food happiness if the
food quality side food quality is based
on goods that count as food grocery all
right god damn it where we where we need
food man we're all right fine fine what
can I say I'm a very generous Presidente
let's build some some goddamn food how
do I build food
build a newspaper have all the newspaper
use independent work mode no that's
ridiculous not gonna be independent
that's already fine I'm going to need
you to vacate the palace why what
happened
money then I do it this is the next one
restart map why would every started what
did I do wrong
I failed oh god damn it
are you kidding me it's their sad
version of say you'll never see me Alexa
this is so sad
this is a dead meme can we play - besito
what god damn it I failed alright well
then let's go out what happened just two
missions now alright fine fine
let's try admissions then that might be
easier okay are there any bridges in
this game not on my watch and shut up
hey look a llama what is this for
tonight do you remember tropical emerald
palm trees platinum beaches and
crystalline seas yes which the Sun
reflects like the twinkling of I'm doing
again
alright I swear to God I cannot read out
half the comments alright let's take it
step by step
there we go very epic alright sugar
I can do that I know how to build sugar
how do I build sugar industry lumber
sugar no processes sugar
which one makes [ __ ] sugar
it must be plantation right there it is
goddamn it I'm a goddamn genius I cute
3,000 thank you
alright let's speed it up a bit come on
I need nukes god dammit I know you can
bill Lord consecrated stuff like a drone
command an aircraft carrier please
let's build a pirate for it I need my
price to do something where do I build
that over here I feel like it's a good
place
let's see if I remember because I also
need to build a where is there a
teamster that's that was that right I
need to build a team support there we go
okay so now the game is teaching me so
after I've done the sugar I need to do
the we're making some rum boys and not
girls that's right I'm 100%
discriminating what do we build it over
here sure you got to think of the future
which I won't have after this video okay
[Music]
can wait for the headlines
I have not it's a video game literally
cry mourn
okay wish you can buy it check out link
inscription there we go
I'm also very generous can I just point
that out I think I've been an excellent
leader so far yes ten Revolutionary
immigrants fine okay fine all right so
we're building the rum distillery now we
need to build a library why why waste my
goddamn time can libraries make me money
I don't think so but you know this is
what I said I'm a generous I'm a
generous man I'm a generous leader this
is actually my resume for the next
president elections you know I'm
actually running for 2020 I won't even
need to do a campaign I'll just submit
this live stream okay alright I don't
care get a random blueprint what do I
get
a dungeon okay that's epic where's the
dungeon
what do I do with that enables you you
and the police to arrest people and keep
them in custody yeah dungeon time
all right let's build the dungeon over
here oh well hidden you know don't want
people near my dungeon dungeon time
arresting people and putting them in
dungeon time whoa look at you all right
I have forgot to buy the trade license
for sugar and what else do I need bill
it teams are poured on each of the three
other islands okay yeah this is much
easier for me to follow
okay wait there's three other islands
god dammit money are in immigrants hmm
money thank you okay so team support I
guess we can build it here perfect god
damn it and another one here where's the
third one
okay won't even miss this it's a volcano
okay epic whoa what is that
epic okay
call now they're all connected okay what
is it only I know what it is a several
dozen loose-lipped freedom fighters oh
my god what do they whine okay what do
they want they want to use independent
work mode oh my god
we need to be a independent ridiculous
this is what I did last time and they
just ended fine
all right Pierre news again there we go
oh my god I need a tannery okay oh yeah
I forgot we need a tannery what do we
build it here great what's the problem
with this then empty stock every goddamn
time work work goddamn it okay we're in
the colonial area
what can we focus on child allowances
Church feed or a circus I guess we need
to get some immigrants in here we need
our city tube
I didn't even swear what are you talking
about
[Music]
okay we built one of the Teamsters we
are building the newspaper it's getting
there
can I just get can we just give a shout
out to all the working people in my city
just shout out to all women as well
major strides have been made guys okay
here they go look at them all right yeah
keep building keep building that's right
dungeon not connected
ah [ __ ] you're right how could I have
been so blind I keep forgetting to
connect everything there we go is that
connected where's the what's the
entrance to the dungeon
oh shoot it's over there isn't it there
we go
perfect god damn you're building slow I
need more people what okay we made it we
made it
coconut harvester SOS all right fine
what else do we need you know what [ __ ]
it let's just take everything what game
is just literally in the title of the
video you goddamn morons you're lucky
you don't live in my city okay coconut
Harvester there we go
oh right by those say of course let's
build the road not a bridge there we go
very nice how is the newspaper not done
yet how long do you need
god dammit PU news
I have not enough people building how
many people are in my city 98 people are
you kidding me you need to pay tax for
the port no I don't what just give me
the money
oh do I need to build more houses is
that the issue maybe that's a she let's
put some more houses guys all right see
how could I have in some plight of
course just need some more houses get
some more people then there we go look
everyone happy now everyone very can you
move god damn it
right next to the dungeon we should
goddamnit whatever doesn't matter
it's just for tonight yeah it is
actually it's fortnight to everybody
this is the latest version take off the
Hat
what hat this is literally merged with
my body I was born like this
sorry okay now they're building thank
God for valaria sánchez shout out to all
the Valerio Sanchez out there yeah you
got them right all right how's this
doing how's the goddamn news how's the
goddamn few news going have in mind okay
I did it got to do a gold mine now I
could probably do that on one of the
islands right um mine so many things
going on alright where did we got there
we go
is that gold Oh on that island okay
perfect look at this approach this is
what I'm frickin talking about who said
I wasn't the best leader of all time
thank you
is that connected no it isn't oh my god
just connect please what did I do wrong
what'd I do wrong there we go
are you connected thank you are you
going to wear the shirt which shirt oh
the Logan thing we'll just have to see
you know we you can change the priority
over there Construction yeah I know I
just figured they would be done by now
okay alright so now I gotta said I guess
view news has to be independent we'll
change it eventually okay we need
immigrants let's get real here
let's get some what about an LSD testing
facility I'm sure you can build that
have at least one teamster port with
upgrade with upgrade deckhands do we
need that on the island of the coconuts
okay so team support like that is that
all you got to do and then we need to
build the goldmine did I built the
goldmine
I forgot I think I did there it is
goddamn it I need more immigrants guys
can you help me out here can anyone
please I need more people in my city
know what we're only a hundred people
goddamn it am I still am I losing money
or gaining money I'm gaining money okay
nice what
wide wide okay fine corn corn they want
corn fine fine I say you want corn you
can have it it's Billy here let's do a
knight oh that was nice a little track
it finished perfectly there we go build
it and I think I need a teamster right I
don't know what a teamster means but it
sounds epic there we go
research child allowances ha don't make
me laugh employee of the month
what am i ring I'm not wearing anything
put the Teamster between our way I need
to read that but teams are between
production and docks what do you think
Oh to maximize the okay so like here is
that what you meant
there's one there right yeah where did I
okay let's demolish that then so like we
need one where am i there is that what
you meant fine let's do that where are
my legs inside my ass why did I say that
[Music]
this game is too smart for you are you
kidding me I'm the most okay yeah give
me immigrants please pirate okay perfect
perfect perfect stone inch time where do
we build a tire all right
I'm learning as I'm going if you guys
want to help just download the game and
figure it out for me please
there's so much to do in this game is
crazy yeah let's build it here uh okay
honestly though I guess like on one of
the islands makes sense yeah right next
to the coconuts no one will expect the
thing
thank you I know I'm doing a great job
okay what games do I recommend I
recommend Tropico six everyone have at
least one teamster port with upgrade
deck oh yeah I forgot that so is this a
this is a teams report with how do I
upgrade why did I broke that one I did
anyway okay I don't care okay okay okay
obviously I need to upgrade this one
it's really fast-paced this game I like
barely keep a nut okay yeah let's do
that
goddammit I need more citizens are you
guys even working here
where's working in yeah you've got damn
best we working Papa needs to get paid
okay okay we'll take it
I need to build another newspaper are
you kidding me
I guess there's a high demand of the
pure news everyone and I should put some
more Tavern right get some more people
in here Oh Tavern is for tourists and
citizens
don't waste my goddamn time he's
building a [ __ ] no we're not we're
building we're building houses okay guys
yeah do you like music too actually
all right bunk house yeah there we go
am i running out of time no maybe that's
why I did so badly last year cuz I just
had it on fast-forward everything oh
yeah I forgot
newspaper all right let's do it
there we go connect it perfectly
connected do it pretty good who's
watching in 2 X can you do that
I got poor X going baby logging camp oh
yeah [ __ ] I forgot okay let's build it
over here then it's got a lot of
immersive logging camp there we go guess
here would make sense
connect the road yeah that's nice and
easy that's not far at all that's pretty
efficient right and then we need a
teamster right see I'm doing great you
need to build it no I don't shut up
no stop you need a better road system
I've got any suggestions
why okay what can I do about this
fisherman more teamster office okay yeah
we should we should definitely be lay
[Music]
where is that fisherman there it is okay
we can be here pervy
[Music]
can I build a bridge I think I actually
meet it extend your mandate I'm where is
that right where where right where where
where where where where help all right
let's visit there I don't know why
there's an option as a reward
know it what
oh yeah I forgot the parrot [ __ ] got way
too many things going on okay fine let's
let's do a heist in summer con as you do
it's over the money button what do you
mean
oh [ __ ] we're losing money boys this is
not good the worst precedent please guys
please through the golden smuggle oh of
course
[ __ ] I'm a returned I mean I'm an idiot
that's what I said okay so there we go
wait what what is it gold smuggle yeah
yeah go smoke okay okay I literally have
the memory of a goldfish can't you do it
oh wait it's doing it
okay program wait you can get external
somewhere your mission
oh I see we need immigrants why who did
this who did this work harder goddamn it
how do I see like how much money it's
making it's doing pretty good get more
coconuts you know what let's get another
coconut absolute Matt light over here
get some more coconuts
currently leading against he series with
635 thousand subs to easy T series to
easy T series saw this livestream and
they realize I'm just too strong
goddamnit
maybe I should not accept all of them
where's my fisherman Wharf goddamnit
maybe I shouldn't accept everything
accepts everything workers cannot reach
this construction site oh yeah [ __ ] got
it but I forgot about their bridge
please cannot build bridges god dammit
okay it's fine it's fine it's fine
I just need to I just need to it's fine
it's fine
honestly it's look at that we did it we
are oh my god we did it I'm so proud I
am so proud I've never been this I
goddamn it
okay it's gotta go like this okay there
it is there it is
look at that look at that just look at
that that's efficiency right fricking
there thank you very much now finish
your goddamn job stop wasting my goddamn
time so guys we did it
that's my best impression ever done
[Music]
the comments are just my last remaining
brain cells Jesus Christ can we have
some normal helpful supportive comments
thank you very much okay what's next but
I bet I swear to God I build a lumber
mill like three [ __ ] years ago why is
it not done yet I was a logging camp
what the hell is the difference
all right let's build out here then
right
doing great feel very proud of the city
oh the parties are back this is great
where does the pirate Cove again it's
co-working whatever it doesn't matter
all right new mission what should we
send them to rescue don't make me laugh
all right let's just do a treasure hunts
oh I think we need to buy some license
that actually I think about it right
[Music]
cold
do I actually I can import no I don't
want to do that export
[ __ ] it's expensive dude
I don't need milk coconut yes banana yes
corn yes had I not been making money all
this time are you kidding me
you're all useless come on I'm only
making money through pirates that's how
you know you're a good leader he just
realized Lowell shut up fine pay
Bright's I don't care
a rescue raid all right I guess Kenz
cancel all your doing
rescue why do I have to rescue people
alright just rescue anyone all right I
don't care and then get me some coconuts
and [ __ ] the mission of the Pirates is
to raid the coconuts this is literally
the coconut farm right here feel pretty
good about this please speak German I'm
pretty sure that's a terrible idea
you're running out of time wait wait
wait where where was that what should I
do trying to read the comments wait what
what do I need to do build the device to
transport vehicle over water like a
submarine or some shut up you're going
to lose the game do more missions I'm
trying I'm freakin trying I'm doing
missions every second have at least one
gold with secret protocol mode okay we
can do that easily because we have mines
over here boys
secret protocol they got done
have an active gold nut export trade
route with smugglers gold nut what the
[ __ ] is gold nut sounds really great
okay well that mission is failed lumber
mill have you not built the goddamn what
[Music]
why did no one tell me huh
why did no one tell me who was it who
was it that never commented I read your
goddamn comments we did tell you when
where and when we told you you needed to
UM
I already bought it you need to get a
propaganda leader called Joseph garbled
and they
that's alright next don't dictate you so
much
excuse me I think I know what I'm doing
I need an egg farm that's what we need
to do just make eggs
don't use Forex you're probably right
about that I'm eating eggs time limit is
in bottom life choose extend many time
permission to extend him that's why you
keep losing okay let's do that then
let's choose a simpler island I'm gonna
play on the hardest mode just so like
cuz that was a bit too easy you are the
worst dictator ever excuse me who's
wearing the Hat okay shut up
I think I'm doing great
yes good meme smuggling ramen for a
master criminal was no more than a hobby
the good old days
you can't even smuggle just cry soon
discovered that he was number one on the
Allies wanted list so began our crash
course in crime and punishment
all right pressure all right all
citizens right to vote what is this
wealthy people gets to vote don't make
me laugh we're a professional soldiers
what kind of what else can I pick just
those two all right
effective until 1923 okay all right
sugar for sugar plantations what do i
what am i rich okay I'm fine one
that's a ranch plantation come on sugar
well you can't even make eggs
you can't harvest eggs ah now I'm really
disappointed fine I guess sugar will
have to do
we can have Lamas though
let me just bail these
okay and now now we get to the real
business I just realize I need one of
these as well
okay well sure what should we focus on
sprite cranberry okay that's not a bad
idea
all right now we can speed up right you
guys just need to work faster all right
so now we need to get a trade license
for sugar and we should get another one
as well for nothing apparently weapons
can we email we can import weapons can
we produce weapons with why we need to
build watchtowers that's no problem just
to overlook the citizens just make sure
they're living a happy healthy life yeah
all right I guess we need to build them
like central there we go there's one
just to make sure everyone is living a
nice happy healthy goodtime life there
we go
[Music]
next up we're building a goddamn what
does the ranch's do we need we need our
crocodile farming I'm serious about god
dammit he wants rum
god dammit the game doesn't want me to
do what I want to do fine all right what
can bill that they're here ever again
now we're gonna build a goddamn
crocodile farm coz that's why I'm here
I don't know about you guys know who
said no about that I'm still I'm making
money well I'm trying
look I got sixty nine percent approval
ah dammit it changed obviously we have
people in this one hire foreign workers
god damn it wow this one has a lot of
workers alright let's get some Hans some
immigrants there we go police station
where is it
Public Services there was the fire
station
where's the police station radio station
oh you can have a nuclear program oh god
damn it I want that come on where's the
police station
am i blind a yacht club space program
inspiring statue I want to have a
spiring statues Cold War I need to be in
the Cold War era government of course
police station right there now my flock
are blessed with faith hope and charity
don't care about you I have a speech
make one more rumbling yeah they're
building they're on their construction
voice
[Music]
Oh actually we don't need that one okay
so we still need to build their pirate
station did I just say pirate station
because that's exactly what I meant
it's music though very nice holy [ __ ]
where is it okay perfect right here
right here where it belongs am i doing
better this time I feel like I am
decrease unemployment rate Wayne Wayne
Wayne I want to build a police station
well I'm already tracer okay where where
died Billy
are you crazy so he doesn't have any
stock alright don't care virgin
okay so pirate comb rebuilt that and
we're building that so let's not fast
forward where the hell are their bananas
that's a great question thank you for
asking that
holy [ __ ] there's a lot of dead memes in
the chain always make me proud brooch
thank you very much
guten tag from the gulag trade okay
except an import trade around with a non
superpower trade partner all right
seems legit they call me the now I don't
want to alarm you but I'm going to need
a rather prompt decision on these offers
okay
labor policy religion unlocks religion
estate that would otherwise cost I don't
care non-superpowered trade what does
that do I figure it'll take a lot except
an import route with an on I don't know
where to do that I'll just abandon that
because I don't know how to do that how
is the police they should not built yet
[Music]
pathetic
who works in this town who's running
this town oh it's cuz I'm like
slow-speed that's why
look at the logo trade license oh it's
there is that it
politics train oh I see oh actually that
was not that difficult [ __ ] I [ __ ]
that cool hat thanks bro
build a Japanese okay great
yeah why is the part thing that's
started that's a great question police
station either Road connection excuse me
what is this they'll make me laugh is it
actually not undercut that's right a
[ __ ] god martial law give me that
why is it not building that's a great
question
build more construction out for the
input open door immigration where do I
do that there's so much to learn about
this game food for people free no lunch
Urban Development we have a lot of
homeless people [ __ ] I need to build
more houses god dammit that's not a
contrast okay perfect
I feel like I should build bunk houses
there we go build more construction of
that it's the Hat part of new merch yes
it's coming out very soon it's gonna
sound like a god so she chose we're
watching carefully I have a feeling so -
I haven't paused I show you right
is that why oh my god are you kidding me
this is why I have edited videos I
sometimes wonder about your final
confession okay fine I'll build a chapel
so you can shut your paper there we go
is that legit why because I had it on
pause am i that [ __ ] stupid the
cringe is good content these guys know
[Laughter]
all right
smugglers trade wrap fulfill export
trade rat with smugglers for rum
that the one
No oh it is and experts have done their
jobs week the US has decided they don't
like to drink it now we got to export
the round alright don't care all right
there's a lot of people asking me for a
lot of things right now export weapons
okay that seems fair
yeah why not we don't produce them but
ya know let's export some weapons
I haven't even build my goddamn bunk
houses yet we really need the chapel
going alright so how do I build weapons
how do I make weapons there we go all
right yeah yeah why not oh god okay yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah why not why not I'm
open for new businesses why not export
some weapons how do i how do I make
weapons again alright this is going
great this is awesome
this is epic guys I said you know what
let's spend some goddamn bunkhouses
you know why cuz I I'm a goddamn good
person how do i I still really haven't
learned the game sixty-eight homeless
citizens well then where where where I'm
homeless literally cry more okay I'm
doing my best here
do you think do you think it's easy for
me huh do you think I have it so nice
huh do you not understand we build a
quarantine camp seems fair that seems
like a good idea
spill a dungeon you never know let's
build a dunya next to my house okay how
is the [ __ ] chapel not done yet I
swear to God
Francisco Ruiz Pablo your old dead
once you finish building this there
better be crocodiles yeah give me give
me my money give me my goddamn money all
right how am i how am I not exporting
rum at this point I can change the
currency is that what I'm doing
[ __ ] there's so many layers to this game
we're learning together guys we're doing
it oh wait this is not changing anytime
soon I need to get the export for there
we go I don't think I can afford
anything more right now
you're not earning money while I'm
trying sheesh what I got to make money
now just wait until I'm exporting my
guns that's what yeah not my promise
I have little pirates looting bananas
and coconuts and coffee and coal and
fish I think I know what I'm doing okay
how do i how do I make money seriously
come on I need to make money a high
priority
it's high-priority time we need to
finish the gun Factory
Papa needs to get paid goddamn it they
need a grocery now no I'm saying no to
that one a prison all right that seems
fair you know what instead of the
dungeon let's have a prison cancel how
do I build a prison there we go yeah
sure why not
there we go I was a nice prison look at
that a prison right next to my house
seems like a great idea I don't know why
I need a prison I just need it okay why
am I not exporting run can someone
explain that to me main quest issue a
prohibit exit god damn it they want so
many goddamn things don't they
first oh okay we're exploiting Roberts
buddy run finally god damn it you guys
are useless
I thought Petey pie was banned yeah well
I will be after this don't worry all
right I need money give me money
export what build bank more houses foods
Tim what are you talking about okay okay
it suddenly said what are we building
we're building handguns that's right
that's a bit lame but at least we're
doing it so what do you need to get
steel and nickel all right [ __ ] okay
[ __ ] I didn't think we would actually
need other stuff okay so we need to mine
for ah [ __ ] how do I make oh there was
nickel there was nickel knowers nickel
nickel nickel nickel alright where can I
make nickel there we go is that nickel
that's really [ __ ] far away isn't it
do we not have any nearer nickel god
[ __ ] okay we can do it here actually
that's perfect oh it's so far away
Stuart here let's just do it here
that's right nickel and then I wrote
because I'm a great guy like that I was
not even that bad
and what else did we need steel import
oh I can just import it that's too
complicated for me I don't know how to
do that
okay nickel import nickel fine I'll buy
a trade license I'll import nickel and
then steel how do I get steel then
another trade license fine it's fine I
have so much money guys so it's fine
export import accept so we're importing
nickel and steel are exporting rum and
sugar and then we're gonna produce okay
this this is epic ice you love the hat
one hat what are you talking about oh my
god so I know how do I eat you there
prohibition people are all drunk if you
intend to profit from this friendship as
you to pass your own provisioning so
there's a rum left to export what the
[ __ ] are you doing
you're gonna go bankrupt soon what are
you talking about I got a lot of money
Papa's got a ton of money I feel like I
should save just in case I fail again
okay okay I don't think any I don't
think any of that how am I not importing
did I say export when I meant import no
it it it is important from Mexico come
on Mexico Mexico please excuse me Mexico
where is my money
Mexico what are you doing
give me my goddamn money you don't have
a port man where you don't have a port
no I have enough stuff to worry about
what is this then huh it's a dog okay
well whatever alright a port fine
whatever thought for sure I had a port
this is ridiculous
oh yeah we need to build a bus [ __ ] the
people can farm the nickel and [ __ ] yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah and then parking we
need parking goddamnit
and then we need another bus goddamnit
oh god my town is too big okay let's do
another bus here so they can get to work
quicker I have a road I have a road what
are you talking about
you're gonna go bankrupt you're - oh
[ __ ] I - money god damn it why did no
one tell me [ __ ] it's fine it's fine
it's fine it happens I mean that it's
fine it's fine it's fine I know what I'm
doing you build a road to your port I
did oh there's it there is already
there's all kinds of stuff here I didn't
even realize have they not been making
me money all right
so I should build a bank is that what
you guys are saying is that how I get
money that's right I can just print my
own money
why make money when you can create money
[ __ ] it can't afford it goddamn it what
port I have a row oh you're right Sian
with what money
huh with what money I don't have time
Papa needs to export my weapons
goddammit I'm poor
how the Frick am I not getting nickel
you need to build a bridge oh my god
shut the [ __ ] up
sorry sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry I just
made I didn't need actual help I have a
praise end it's right next to my house
please building someone
build the bridge to the other nickel
chef you got deer mouth I don't need a
bridge because I have a road a road have
you heard of it
it's a [ __ ] road I don't need a
bridge Jesus Christ hey look who's
making money huh look who's making money
I know what I'm doing
goddamn pissed me off you almost have
enough money to buy a bank thank you
helpful comment you aren't anymore in
bankruptcy
yeah that's how you say that okay so now
okay you know what we're doing so
goddamn good I'm saving the game just in
case I mess up look how much rumburak
sporting dude goddamn genius
I don't know what this is don't care
[Music]
you're billing to many things at once
yeah you're probably right about that
it's just so addicting to build stuff
look how happy everyone is by the way
can we talk about how great of a leader
I am everyone is having fun look how
happy everyone is
look how house everyone is I I'm
actually not doing that bad by the bank
you're goddamn right I'm buying a bank
all right where's the bank Popeye needs
to print some money I can't afford it
you oh I can't all right we're in depth
again hope you guys thanks for the tip
guys really appreciate it all right what
are you guys waiting oh yeah keep
raining [ __ ] theater
lame okay oh thank god we did something
Crime and Punishment okay okay this is
epic
oh you're in - god dammit I am creative
of the help you're giving presidency I
tell the chaps in the club good sorts
those truck I guess I have to accept
that we have nickels guys we have nickel
we have two weapons we made two weapons
oh my god guys guys guys guys I think
I'm doing pretty good
we made two guns we made two fourteen
the nickel is coming are they're finally
coming - stupid workers they are walking
to June they're walking the idiots are
walking stop now why are you walking I
built a bus station goddammit take the
butt
god damn it calm down fix okay
where's the goddamn [ __ ] bus station
that's a parking station where's the
goddamn bus station oh no I'm getting a
hand green I'm getting really angry
they're walking the whole goddamn
gangway oh I did something oh wait sorry
okay okay okay all right we're making
guns like a cop at church one where's
Quan showed up Quan follow up on Quan
what is he doing
all right mo nica oh my god you idiots
all right where's my workers where's my
record he's in the house country-ass
Blancas oh they're not working right now
we're like where where are their jobs
okay so how far did it worked
okay this step parking why don't I need
to build that I need to build that Hey
look we're up in money now I need the
lab
where is it where it [ __ ] is it the
bus station
bus station but state bus station oh I
can build a steel mill okay that's good
then I don't have the import step okay
now we build the wall guys pink okay
yeah yeah yeah oh dammit dammit god
dammit [ __ ] god [ __ ] dammit why do
you know what tell me before build house
next to mines bill house next to mines
of course then they don't have to walk
it genius I'm a goddamn genius I did not
read the comments here you gotta have a
house let's on Papa have another one son
me voice whoa goes to buy bus station
bye Steve you need to mine Aaron now why
why why why why why why dude I'm making
steel like a goddamn nickel mine oh you
never built that you idiots you frickin
Fricks just oh oh we're plus four plus
four plus uh you made some profit okay
let's not waste any more money Felix
stop wasting your goddamn money stop
buying stuff why what is happening why
is it getting dark did we almost did the
rum quest I don't care don't care we
need to build a customs office okay
let's build a customs love it wait I
don't have enough money oh yeah
don't spend money save the game you're
goddamn right I'm doing amazing you're
right okay come on guys come on guys
maybe once we done with this we can
actually like build the [ __ ] Bank
get some bit connect in here oh that
would be so sweet
I'm gonna build a bank here in the
center what would be the currency for
for me few coins don't say it don't say
it okay
Bank oh [ __ ] what happened to my money
who keeps taking my money
[Music]
[Laughter]
sometimes I wish I was an unknown
youtuber I can actually make I read the
comments
[Music]
Sarah deaf like zero money I have an
embassy invite access to embassy okay we
can do that we can do that how do I do
that
oh the axis how do I do that no I don't
how do I invite them
do I need an embassy or something
stop importing oh [ __ ] you're right I'm
importing why do you know what [ __ ]
tell me I don't need this [ __ ] get the
[ __ ] out
oh that's what's cussing me all the
money but goddamn and I'm making money
though am i export I may be even
exporting the [ __ ] weapons no I'm not
export import weapons export there we go
now we'll make money customs office
don't build it wait what do you say
don't build houses build a complex okay
I'll do it next time all right yeah
let's cancel leaves I ain't got time why
am I losing money now what do they do
that's why they call them Goods because
it's good dude we can get so much money
from
Eric phones when Adam front strand
please please guys help me on this one
build the bank with what money
shut up all right next one that tells me
to build a goddamn [ __ ] bridge insta
permabanned for a year okay what do I
need actually
I need an embassy well with one 100 the
fast fast we need to work fast where is
the bank
give me my bank ah oh hell yeah oh oh
look at it look at it it's beautiful
where do I please it I don't have space
for the bank bank please oh okay all
right yeah let's see a nice pillar here
that's a fancy ass Bank by the way looks
like a cheese sorry where's the entrance
of the bank
I don't want to like bill I'll build it
here and then it looks like benders is
here
all right we're building the Bank boys
it's happening you have an embassy
already oh I have an embassy already
thanks for that tip we're library Church
embassy axis here we go
send delegation is that what I'm doing
the man completed oh we did it hold this
[ __ ] give me money give me money I don't
know how to do that prohibition from an
old emo road to bank oh [ __ ] you're
right well I don't know where the
entrance is
I don't know what the answers is so I'm
not gonna do it build a toilet jesus
[ __ ] christ I guess I have to build a
customs office I don't really want to oh
no no no no no no no but the game is
telling me I guess I have to
[Music]
I wish I could see where the entrance is
it's kind of hard to tell I think it's
like this oh [ __ ] why did no one tell me
I'm poor alright okay great great
I don't have time for that right now
build your alligator farm this that's
the end goal all right
you have to work your way to get there
I'll build a road to the bank when it's
[ __ ] built or now okay pine I don't
know where the entrances that's the
problem but I should do it right article
13 people are drunk issue a prohibition
X wears prohibition good money making
good money good money guys
research in thing newspaper whoa what
just happen oh we completed a raid
awesome we get money from they alright
heist so niche sells news good idea are
we actually making good money from this
we're not even using the steel mill
because it's never finished its the game
paused oh god it's the game pause no I
wasn't why is no-one building [ __ ] am i
building too many stuff again I'm not
swearing shut up I would never say a
swear oh [ __ ] we lost money again voice
we lost money again voice you actually
hovered over the prohibition are you
kidding me alright
where
bish where I was just at the prohibition
where which one is it
the prohibition is where you did the
newspaper thing what what
holy [ __ ] [ __ ] I'm rich I'm [ __ ]
rich research oh my god oh my god oh my
god oh my god
prohibition prohibition prohibition
where is it
prohibition where is it ah [ __ ] oh it's
happening it's happening
Oh things are happening now things are
happening boys I'm a goddamn genius
you're right I'm a goddamn genius
literally touched in three he can swear
I'm not swearing shut up
I would never customs office thank you
guys for helping me by the way I don't
think I could have done this without you
this is great
prohibition no wait customs office
construction team Street custom there
must be like government building right
no
bish where you already started our
customs next to the bank I knew that I
knew that are you kidding me fulfill
import trade route with access okay we
could probably do that right how do I do
that [ __ ] I need to stop accepting
things that I don't understand the dad
do it oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] I accepted one I
didn't mean to loot expel access from
embassy okay I guess I did that the man
failed oh [ __ ] I [ __ ] that [ __ ] now
I'm scared
I'm saving I'm saving again fulfill
import trade road with axis why would I
expel it then
where is it
you're becoming a Nazi why would you say
that
[Music]
I don't know how I got on this ride I'm
not actually trying you need iron to
make steel ah [ __ ] ah [ __ ] I need to
mine is that what you're saying
steel cold no I need coal and iron are
you kidding me fiction everyone else
yeah we don't in the day okay we need
what was it
I forgot Iren and iron and coal [ __ ] all
right what can we mine
goddamn it is so [ __ ] far away dude
all right we're just gonna have to do it
cold there and then shut up listen
listen I ain't got time wait what would
I build I built coal and iron iron
listen I'm I'm trying I'm [ __ ] trying
there we go
now let's make a nice little road nice
little road Jesus Christ
[Music]
and uh god damn me we have to make a
bridge fine
are you happy now are you happy are you
satisfied doing good feel very proud of
this city I don't have a customs office
yet are you kidding me how is this not
built yet oh it's almost done
oh it's going fast now boys we have the
bank all right now we're gonna get the
money
finally the [ __ ] bank generates
filthy rich okay let's just do a normal
[ __ ] bag I'll take the money trade
route do I do that with a harbor maybe
[Music]
no build bus station by mines oh you're
right okay I need to do that is it bus
garage
[Music]
yeah
it is isn't he oh my god the comments
are [ __ ] again God - I mean stupid
again that's right in order made a train
ride I'd already made a trade rat what
the [ __ ] does that mean I don't want to
let down Eric Fernstrom you know like
god dammit it's just starting or ending
I don't know [ __ ] I don't know god
[ __ ] damn it this is a bus garage
what it what is a bucket oh my god help
me
this is the bus it's a [ __ ] parking
bus crush quick build start
why it's not connected to a road yeah
this okay okay okay
[Music]
did I not build one all right we're just
gonna have to quick build ending there
we go they can walk home dude look how
much money we have hold this [ __ ] the
shadow so fast I'm trying but no sorrows
oh god damn it [ __ ] oh I just need one
of them setup bus ride so workers can I
use it okay so I I basically what I need
to do is where the [ __ ] is it holy [ __ ]
I'm lost in my own City so you're
telling me so you're telling me so
you're telling me I just pray a start
and then I just place an end is that it
oh my [ __ ] god so that there's no
point in building that I [ __ ]
all right now they can go back and forth
and [ __ ] I don't [ __ ] know and then
start here right and then am i doing
here I think I'm think I'm doing a
pretty epic
alright now you can go to work alright
and stop wasting my [ __ ] time and
make some goddamn guns thank the bus
driver did you see that referencing
rewind I don't even get it the first
time I was like that's pretty cringy
line build more houses where and where
we need more houses okay but this time
we build actual [ __ ] houses yeah
apartments yeah we can afford that
[Music]
I don't know where the front and back is
of this okay I'll give a speech about
okay perfect it's election time oh [ __ ]
am I gonna win it all right well
everyone has a job and everyone loves
the Communists and we're gonna blame the
Allies and also did I say that all the
jobs are great oh my god yes he has no
legs
he's got no legs it's the beta version
guys okay that's why there's some ghosts
I'm glitches I think he's supposed to be
up here no legs mode build the
businesses buy the houses okay that's a
good idea
I'm not the one who who's [ __ ] rich
as shake set the Constitution to
pacifists than waste my time woman build
even more houses are you guys [ __ ]
crazy issue prohibition again how do I
do that save the game okay good idea
thank you build the proper residential
area they're not I can't even build two
houses all right calm down guys we're
we're prohibition we're you guys lied to
me
I could do nuclear testing come on I
want to do that should I give them free
lunch food for the people that's
ridiculous
you just gave a two-month long speech oh
my god why are you not doing anything
you [ __ ] steal mail god damn it I
thought we had a deal of oh they're not
constructed yet all right I ain't got
time
work work god damn it let's hire some
people food has left the chair all right
come on finish it I need to make weapons
it's my main source of income
I'm not [ __ ] swearing please all
right
maybe in a couple of years we can build
some nuclear [ __ ] what is this what do
you want resource depleted by [ __ ] [ __ ]
all right we build a new logging camp
ting
ok is there anything else we need I
think we're pretty much perfect all
right how do I do this how do I do this
fulfill alright I'm not leaving the
comments sell stuff to access via trade
read research the bank okay that's it
that's all I gotta do let's check out
the bank and of course what I need to do
is I what the [ __ ] are you guys smoking
what are you talking about build another
construction company can you eat
obsidian sell the mill that they will
replant the trees not cut them down oh
okay
Road to the bank it has a road shut up
don't forget the bus stop next near the
other mind it's fine they can walk the
last bit build the road to the bank it
has a [ __ ] road can you not see it in
turns right there
choose pirate missions you guys are very
demanding treasure hunting there you go
axis trade route Eric Fernstrom
please you haven't been importing steel
for a while not named while you're not
naming it's so not okay listen I'll make
it my own [ __ ] steel oh god damn it
they're not making any steel alright
fine we're gonna have to trade in some
steel exports steel imports steel fine
fine just cuz I need money I'm not
desperate
you need you need to make trade alliance
with the excess power check the license
menu maybe maybe maybe maybe they said
maybe they said [ __ ] where fish where
axis trade round which one we're already
exporting [ __ ] cigars and [ __ ]
don't forget about the election don't
worry I know what I'm doing people love
me in this town a bridge [ __ ] shut up
please
you need to set up the trade route when
you import US Steel give it some time to
update what tropicals under attack
what the [ __ ] who sits hacking me oh god
they're targeting my bank oh god now I
gotta build a military god [ __ ] damn
it
let's see series guys they've done it
now I'm building barracks I got a build
barracks god [ __ ] damnit that's over
I'll bid again next to my house and I
need it
Oh God God is this the end of PewDiePie
oh [ __ ] they're at our god [ __ ]
damnit t-series stop oh [ __ ] this is
like Normandy oh god they're gonna
bridge soon
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
God army I need an army I need an army
I need a nine year old army guys please
I'm building it [ __ ] shut up shut up I
don't care communists demand research
freewheels
okay fine what the [ __ ] is that
no no no I don't care I'm not doing
communism
first tab on trade routes first tab no I
already have it you [ __ ] [ __ ]
the [ __ ] are you smoking ah
they're attacking my weapons alright
alright
desperate times desperate measures we
have barracks now build a building oh
wow
most top 10 most helpful comments bail
constriction offers it faster oh yeah I
did I did it I did it
prohibition is in the Constitution okay
where's the Constitution again I'd swear
I've seen that I can't change the
Constitution until 1923 which is very
soon actually my election rating is
going down god [ __ ] damn it you're
right
alright military strength okay it looks
like they are they are definitely voting
for me cuz I'm an amazing leader I don't
consider myself just a leader I consider
myself a friend so yeah we're not gonna
mess with the election at all
I need to build library so I can speed
up the process okay cool I'll build a
library
this is library are the attackers coming
now have you not [ __ ] finished this
yet I swear to God oh we did every day
every day we actually did it we actually
did it I'm crying and shaking right now
oh just give me a migrant I don't even
care issue fry we're still on [ __ ]
penalty no more prohibition exhibit zero
death by the way can I can we just get a
shout-out to zero deafs everyone train
an army in my base we're defensive
engage with the attackers take em out
boys take them out boys take them out
this is a great strategy take him out
take them out
the election can we talk about how great
I am at this game now now that I'm the
new president again uh everyone citizens
gets to vote what can I say I'm a great
leader and we need to have a maybe lower
the military they're all strictly
legitimate okay find circuit there you
go
what does that mean let's ask for
financial aid okay yeah we were to have
that expell access from embassy what
but I did it i oh we did it right away
job happiness needs to increase how do I
make them happier stop complaining so
goddamn much how about that have you
thought about that how am I not making
any more goddamn weapons oh I am making
weapons okay great
because we're important steel if this
making steel we're [ __ ] making steel
boys we're making Steel's things are
happening right now we only export
weapons do we import anything no we
don't you know why because we're making
our steel goddammit it's actually
happening boys it's actually [ __ ]
happening look at it when a war
oh it's time I think it's time to invade
I think we're strong enough to kill some
some people how the [ __ ] do I do this
okay fine I'm bored fulfill import sorry
I can't do that again I'm not doing that
again okay I need your help guys no
where are the tanks they're out killing
people
what the [ __ ] is going on
excuse me this is life this is real life
this is all that matters okay
part of the game is building merit with
either the Allies or taxes you'd be
better stein depending on trade route
submission you already have some access
points so do them yeah that's what I'm
doing
okay tell me something I didn't know
local Beauty damn we look pretty in this
town make it oh my god shut up
god [ __ ] damn it all right I guess we
can do some I don't even need this [ __ ]
I just need money cancel cancel cancel
oh [ __ ] I can't I'm under attack no I'm
not oh I am I have whatever what
anything gonna do huh
what are they [ __ ] gonna do engage
the attackers
okay I think we're doing pretty [ __ ]
good are they fighting over here what
are they shooting at you know you're
shooting at nothing right this this man
David Ramos Ramos David Ramos just died
I'm so sad about that I'm not okay with
David Ramos I'm slowly learning the game
but it's getting more fun the more you'd
understand it but I feel like the more I
learned that lesson
I understand okay let's give them some
frames prohibition issue prohibition I
[ __ ] did it I did it I've done it a
million times the prohibition please
goddamn me we have a lot of homeless
people still okay let's build some
houses over make a crocodile farm [ __ ]
you're right we haven't done it yet I
can't believe it spilled some apartments
over here
holy [ __ ] this game is intense okay so
now it's just useless don't waste my
time a system or logging camps can hurt
right
why can't I not build it
am I even exporting [ __ ] logs just
hit me why not
[Music]
hopefully [ __ ] [ __ ] I'm losing boats
why I'm doing great
look how great I'm doing I'm making so
many weapons I won the war
you got damn right I won the war is
anyone surprised is anyone actually
surprised this is why you need to join
my country I actually really need job
happiness how the [ __ ] the way increase
job happiness making people less
unemployed okay what if I kill all the
unknit alright well how about we arrest
all the people that are unemployed okay
that makes sense right we just put them
in jail and that way they can just work
from jail that's how you increase job
happiness everyone in case you didn't
know
[Music]
labor policy yeah maybe that helps oh my
god Eric fun [ __ ] strand fine fine
how do we do that again I actually
forgot uh neurotically I forgot
[Music]
they took our jobs what the [ __ ] is this
oh yeah you're going to jail [ __ ]
that's right if you ain't working you go
to jail what can I say I'm a fair
country maybe hospitals will make them
happier we haven't actually done a power
plan that might be cool we actually have
some money now right and if we have a
power plan I know you can build some
entertainment like I put a funfair and
[ __ ] like that build a theater where
movie theater it's got to be in the Cold
War oh my god bruh bruh save the game
you goddamn right I'm saving the game I
appreciate you guys help me out on this
I need how to take all the help I can in
build the restaurant so they can eat
where and where we need to eat no you
know what no no more build this no more
build that no more build schools
no more build this I'm not building
anything until my hand my goddamn
crocodile farm okay that's what I wanted
to do at the very start and I think I've
earned myself some [ __ ] crocodile
farms I'm building how many goddamn
crocodile want of farms that I so
goddamn pleases me that's how you say
that thank you
another crocodile farm you think I'm
done [ __ ] off crocodile farming is
really gonna take off you don't know
there's the demand for crocodiles these
days in 1924 people want crocodile farms
it's not just me
why crocodiles good question
now we got to make sure that we export
the crocodiles what should we do what a
[ __ ] do I do with the crocodiles
it's crocodiles actually [ __ ] useless
[Music]
I'm creating jobs that's what I'm doing
I'm an excellent president Thanks
well I can keep the crocodiles and I can
leather leather of course leather of
course that's what I do with the life
all right so we're gonna start exporting
leather is we're gonna bout to have a
lot of [ __ ] leather going on voice
where's the [ __ ] leather there we go
import leather no export leather [ __ ] I
can't do it yet I guess we're not
producing it yet
all right let's quick a bit let's quick
build the crocodile farm house my
crocodiles that's what I'm talking about
look at that look they have a little
[ __ ] and everything oh my god look at
this we are winning the war and we're
making a crocodile farm and job
happiness is not increasing even though
I put people to jail that whirring oh my
god all right job happiness can I check
that out health care quality fun fave
food fun happiness
perfect
this is this is the dream I'm living the
dream right now I don't need militaries
I'm doing the access route finish Lu
[Music]
oh that's right I need to build more
houses I forgot
[Music]
if you guys want to check out Tropico as
well link in the description fun time
help me out as well so I can know how to
actually play the game that would be
great
I can't even [ __ ] build it there
listen bills and bunkhouses are you
kidding me
if you expel the access you can be able
to bigger pie okay all right let's do
that we did it
[Music]
did I get good yet I think I'm pretty
goddamn good how's the crocodiles doing
they're doing fantastic this is what I'm
talking about this is how I have this
amount of money we're losing people's
votes [ __ ] you're right what am i doing
run just 88 hey I have a 120 1000 and
you know why
crocodiles goddamn crocodiles making me
a [ __ ] fortune look how much leather
I have dude am I actually exporting
leather though oh my god I have actually
I can't export leather are you kidding
me are you [ __ ] kidding me
I can only import leather alligator
farms are useless
no no Oh meat okay yeah no no no no no
no meat milk can you milk alligators
surely you can milk alligators
how do I milk alligators save the game
yeah you can milk them okay great
good thank you
prohibition is under addicts money you
still haven't done the mission since 30
minutes ago
shut up I mean thank you oh my god oh my
god I did it it was that easy huh oh my
god this changes everything now I gotta
build restaurants and [ __ ] for his
restaurant I swear I've seen it like a
million [ __ ] there it is yeah give me
a restaurant a rest drop against you now
at Lauren RA we can arrest wrongdoers
well I arrested a ton of people what are
you talking about all right we're gonna
have to arrest some people guys all
right so who's not happy all right so
again we're gonna have two special
citizens we have two criminals arrest
okay can I just kill them then all right
we have 12 unemployed people so because
they're uneducated ah I need a school
can I build schools
College goddamn I'm the best goddamn
people I have not peed in two and a half
hour jesus [ __ ] christ
[Music]
turn your bridges for fucksake past the
game did I not pause the game I am
panicking because I didn't pause the
game why am i crocodile range is not
[ __ ] build yet and you know what I'm
done with this
[ __ ] the Crockett house oh my god I'm
rich at least there's a school build yet
[ __ ] it build it [ __ ] it build it now
that I have a PowerPoint I can build the
[ __ ] high school first ah [ __ ]
where's the highest [ __ ] [ __ ] alright
here you go
done export hide where
oh I see so that's what happens when we
do it we're not exporting any [ __ ]
logs why not I thought I had a long
business what's happening here place
oh my god oh my god need more immigrants
you're right [ __ ] go to school
military education this game is so
complex seriously the people in jail we
got to free them from jail so they can
go to school
hi you're free I Adam
disaster of disasters the crew is so why
did I spend five thousand guys can you
go out of jail because I need you to get
a job I'm losing votes I know I know
the bill the barrack near the dock why
holy [ __ ] shed that what happened I
went to pee and stop making fun of me
please I'm losing money job happiness
literacy program that would make sense
build the Empire and destroy t-series
that's actually a great idea although
already getting destroyed by the way are
you actually walking to job you [ __ ]
idiot why are you going to jail now we
were ready to order the rocks but
suddenly there were druids everywhere
I think I'm doing good but I can't tell
they rebuild the restaurant by the way
quick bill damn that filled up fast
so we've got to make sure it's safe well
it's right next to a [ __ ] army base
so I think it's safe it arrested
criminals edgy what's up/ok criminals
got it
where's the [ __ ] criminals I keep
forgetting where everything is there we
go
special citizens there's a [ __ ] rebel
I'll kill him crime lords kill them all
oh my god there's so many criminals I'm
sorry but you're all gonna have to die
all right well bribe one and see what
happens
I'm a good leader shut up Hey look look
everything is going great only eight
unemployed citizens I think that's
pretty good
Swedish dictator
I guess this school is working
you put the college next to this
crocodile farm don't question me all
right build more houses for [ __ ] sake
okay fine you don't have to swear at me
yeah good call cool guy thank you for
the suggestion wait I have 150 homeless
where and where I'm home late maybe we
should build more [ __ ] roads instead
of me yeah building neighborhood
there you go enjoy your houses [ __ ] alt
f4 to boost money really wow that's
really cool actually I have enough money
so maybe I won't do it now but thank you
for the suggestion I'll definitely use
it later Lock them up reallocation
program oh my god you can actually do
that that's awesome 50% approval [ __ ]
how do i how do I deal with these idiots
what do you think why huh the
capitalists are they happy with okay
the task is done oh thank god
immigrants never thought I'd say that
that was a joke okay um [ __ ] emptying
stock are you kidding me I don't have
nickels [ __ ] we need to aim for nickels
import nickel import nickel import
nickel here we go
20% above standard [ __ ] [ __ ]
what are you doing then kill her kill
her kill her kill her kill her please
kill okay
[ __ ] pirates goddamn their actual
pirate all right you did your thing
right
thank you finally
where are the bridges they're online
they're easy floor we need to build
another barracks okay fine I can do that
right next to the bank where they belong
now of course it's here
Rex is that dangerous that yeah it's
really fast cool job happiness Felix I'm
trying first of all I gotta arrest these
[ __ ] [ __ ] do I not have place in
my prison is that why I can't arrest
more yeah I can so why can I not kill
him
I have a [ __ ] crime lord in my town
cuz they're homeless I guess I can just
kill them I'm sorry guys not enough
workers holy [ __ ] [ __ ]
when are you nuking you know what it's
time to build a [ __ ] it's nuking time
let's do a save here I'm gonna just I'm
gonna play really good the last that the
last of this I'm gonna make sure I do a
great job actually we built quite a lot
actually I'm proud of this town I'm
proud of this city okay we're gonna
build a [ __ ]
what is this [ __ ] we can't build it
goddamn it can be building Cold War [ __ ]
I really wanted to build it is anything
cool we can build a snorkel Bay
you
and ministry was what's fun about a
ministry
you
guess we need another police station
you're right because we need to arrest
the [ __ ] [ __ ]
you
right next to the mansions quick bill
what is this guy doing I hate them build
a rollercoaster is that actually good
I can build a rule because modern times
can only do it I can build a funfair up
here
wait the pier doesn't actually go in the
water must be placed on a beach reaching
into water okay there we go okay I think
I'm back I don't know if anything
happened basically I am I did a lot of
amazing stuff in case you're curious
okay you guys are [ __ ] useless
holy [ __ ] where do I build the prison
can a man just build the prison
goddammit thank you done absolute man
line stream offline is it still offline
refreshing and should be back although
you can't hear me say refresh so I don't
it's 4x time baby am I able to arrest
people now
why not [ __ ] is it lagging what happened
I'm building prisons shut up guys hey
livestream was down all right I know
what I'm doing look at this
I'm building [ __ ] prisons mahkumat
can I now arrest them oh now I can
arrest them
great shut up
don't try and bribe yourself into me
that sounded weird yeah well you're
going to jail so stop kissing my ass no
you cannot you're dead
[Music]
Oh God oh yeah they're going to jail
five arresting job happiness is actually
going up how about that guys
[Music]
export rum and sugar build more
watchtower for safety okay thanks
forgot about watchtowers I kind of need
them everywhere don't I you can look in
the map I know military strength oh okay
maybe some stuff here everyone has to do
their part guys or usually when you're
apart can you guys build a little
[ __ ] slower please
alligators high-tech sport yeah you're
right but I can't do it look where is it
I don't have it
build a tenner you make leather holy
[ __ ] cyka be otten god dammit don't
okay alright let's just make sure I
arrest all the people now oh I have to
be a little on the small island I
[ __ ] build it here [ __ ] [ __ ] cancel
[ __ ] I'm an idiot
oh [ __ ] [ __ ] why did no one tell me on
the small I of course of course
okay alright this is that big I didn't
know that that's funny that means we had
gonna have to build well you guys have
been waiting for this whole time a
branch that's right everybody I did it
finally yeah yeah he actually did it the
thing that you have not been shutting up
about three [ __ ] hours I'm so tired
yeah they abused where's the [ __ ]
crazy
[Music]
how am I gonna fit three prisons in the
air what am i prison Marie okay I'm
trying to build prisons over here guys
don't waste my [ __ ] time okay
what in the world is happening there we
did it
I'm salute man Lance and job happiness
is going up amazing absolutely amazing
I'm doing so great atomic bomb did
someone just say atomic bomb it's time
no I don't want allies abandon I do I
still need to [ __ ] arrest people how
are you not arrest at all yet oh yeah
cuz I demolished some prisons you're
right [ __ ] oh it needs power I know how
to do that I'm like a kid at a amusement
park well I might distraction is just
changing every second that's a sentence
yes it is okay you build
where are they I can build a stone-age
yeah I don't see why not
I don't see why not there it is thank
you for that that was definitely worth
it
[Music]
vehicle Juicery
can find it oh [ __ ] you're right I need
to slow down speed I don't care about
the alley I don't care how is he so
blind thank you
I have a problem yeah but I need to
connect in the hospital don't make me
laugh
export rum again am I not doing that
have I not been doing that all this
[ __ ] time I'm making guns yeah me
come rub
oh I'm not exporting it [ __ ] why didn't
you tell me leather I can only import
rum are you kidding me so I'm just
sitting on a bunch of [ __ ] rum I'm
actually not making any money at all
right now is that what's happening
all right this is great let's get the
[ __ ] rebels arrested please are you
kidding me I'm gonna lose it I'm gonna
say neighbor okay finish it just finish
it I ain't got time I don't care up or I
am you're all going to jail arrest
you're arrested you're arrested please
tell me that's ten of them I'm not a
cruel dictator I don't know what you're
saying
okay almost there brush export hymens
was there are you serious was it
we're fish wait I don't see am i blind
again important all right we can export
lungs so we should probably get in some
more longer shape lumber mills right do
they make long serve yeah the most so
anything else logging camp cuts on
trades to produce logs okay perfect
let's do that Papa needs to get paid
let's build those fast cuz they're
[ __ ] cheap and then we build a lumber
mill right next to it and then we build
Teamsters office now make me [ __ ]
money please I'm desperate let's get
some foreigners in there real [ __ ]
pants is this gonna work I have no idea
chocolate goes under attack oh [ __ ]
why without my presence not my fellow
prisoners can I just be happy for once
can I just live a happy life why are
there so many goddamn criminal
[Music]
I need to start exporting along so
you're right
thank you guys I am I am I am banana
business let's do it we're going into
banana business place how do I make
bananas how do I make bananas guys
that's the [ __ ] ranch you idiot
plantation it's been at a time all right
where's good for bananas it's banana
time voice things are really starting to
pick up here I feel it more bananas
that's right more bananas that's a
[ __ ] banana I'm bananas
goddammit bananas please oh my god
please there it is
it's banana time
build it build it banana time look how
much money I'm making
oh god I have no money at all how I have
I not build the [ __ ] prison
kellen aah what happened what happened
there
ah the restaurant safety is terrible I'm
losing money Hey why finish it already
banish the [ __ ] friends and however I
not arrested them all goddamn yet erase
the please arrest
I am yesh thanks for asking I just need
to arrest one more Oh your face are but
shut up I need help
yeah sure
a Lu train feel like my pyres are
[ __ ] useless let's loot some [ __ ]
bananas boys you can't arrest without
money try me I'm making money ah [ __ ] I
don't think that's good I really don't
think that's good it's alright we don't
have to look at it right now
no yeah maybe I was invading
this is so sad
I can't believe I'm not crying shut up I
messed up I messed up guys the fall Oh
[Music]
it's a so sad
F in the chat voice F in the goddamn
chat
[Music]
I got invaded and I missed that failure
bro time for me to step down and sit
here
I realize now this is my actual hair
hair right now that's great
oh my god [ __ ] gross
you fought we fought hard load up your
last save no I've been playing for three
hours I think I need a break it's
because I build the bridge you're right
ever since I built the bridge everything
just went downhill I'm not gonna lie no
me it means a sign that was a terrible
idea I think there wasn't enough rages I
think you're a goddamn [ __ ] big goof
all right I hope you guys had fun I had
a lot of fun playing Tropico if you guys
want to check out this game I recommend
it it's a lot of fun link is in the
description check it out see if you can
do it better than me I don't think you
can but you can try I need a stronger
military I need a strong a referee's
thing okay but this is not the time I
tried and tried got Timmy I don't have
enough money I'll just farm some bananas
then it's not that hard
when will I stream again I don't know
but it was fun I enjoy it I hope you
guys had fun as well I need it to far
more crocodiles alright enough were they
in hindsight's it's always easy to say
what I'm gonna do but obviously what I
needed to do better was nothing because
I think I did a perfect job and that was
practically impossible there was nothing
that I could have done to change
anything
yeah I will stream or I actually really
enjoy it and I have internet now as well
thanks you guys for helping me out and
being patient with me it's fun I enjoyed
the interaction and that you guys helped
me nothing bad happens
hey how about that how about that
alright I got a video coming up now if
you guys want to check that out
and I'll see you guys next time
epic brofist I'm professed professed
epic professed epic there it is epic
profesh I don't think I can zoom more
roughest epic oh yeah